robo bees no it isn't a sci-fi flick
coming to a theater near you it is a
research project from a team of
brainiacs at the Harvard School of
Engineering and Applied Sciences a
robotic honeybees with an itty-bitty
synthetic wings and a teensy weensy
synthetic body and a computer chip for a
brain of all the insects why recreate
bees because a third of our food and 90%
of the planet's flowering crops rely on
honey bee pollination and for the past
decade honeybee colonies have diminished
by an average of 20 to 30 percent each
year why is this so called colony
collapse disorder happening many studies
point to a specific crop insecticide
that is used around the world enter
robots because they solve everything
in 2009 the National Science Foundation
sponsored a team of Harvard researchers
to pursue work in micro aerial vehicle
swarms controlled by a central hive
computer kind of like a queen bee and
after three years the first robobee took
flight for ten seconds Harvard says
it'll be at least two decades until
they'll have robots that can spread
pollen so it's probably not the most
viable solution to the bee collapse but
there's more to this artificial
insectoid than helping mother nature
researchers say Robo bees could also be
used for mapping search and rescue
missions crowd monitoring and military
surveillance big bumble is watching in
fact award-winning roboticists Robert
Wood the head of Harvard's research team
used to be funded by the Defense
Advanced Research Projects Agency or
DARPA DARPA is the nerd wing of the US
Department of Defense
you might remember DARPA from such
innovative hits
drones and for coming military robots
which is why both peace and
environmental activists feel
particularly stung by robobee Greenpeace
says instead of replacing these with
robots we should change the way we farm
is this the future we want for
agriculture a solution and a way out of
the current industrial agricultural
crisis does exist it's called ecological
farming ecological farming works with a
diversity of nature to produce healthy
food for all and at the same time
protects the planet and bees so Israel
will be the key to the planets future or
is all this just one big honey trap